So there won't be any phase kickback involved in this algorithm, it's just not how this one works.
Other than the differences
I just mentioned though, it looks very similar to
the Deutsch-Jozsa circuit.
We apply a layer of Hadamard gates, then we apply a query gate one time, and then we apply another
layer of Hadamard gates
followed by standard basis measurements of the top n qubits.
The idea is that each time we
run this circuit and measure, we'll get some string y that tells us something
about the hidden string s
in Simon's problem. And by running the circuit
several times independently, we will have gathered enough
statistical evidence about s
to be able to figure out what
it is with high confidence.
Now let's analyze the quantum
circuit for Simon's algorithm to see what it does.
The state after the first
layer of Hadamard gates looks like this, similar to what we had for
the Deutsch-Jozsa algorithm.
Except this time, the bottom m qubits are all in the 0 state
rather than in minus states.
After the query gate is performed, we see that the value f of x has been written onto the
bottom or leftmost m qubits,
and that's because f of x has been XORed onto the all-zero string.
So again, there's no phase kickback happening in this algorithm.
We then perform the second
layer of Hadamard gates.
And using the same formula as before for the action of a
layer of Hadamard gates on a standard basis
state, cat x in this case,
as it was in the original formula, we obtain this state right here, where the action of the Hadamard gates
has been made more apparent. But if we want to, we can also write the state
in a more compact form like we have right here.
At this point, we measure the top n qubits to obtain some end bit string y, and we just need to figure
out what the probabilities are
for the different strings. And that'll help us to understand
what information we get from this string y about the string s
that's hidden inside of the function f.
We're going to need
some more room for this, and we really don't need
the circuit diagram anymore, so let's get rid of it and give ourselves some
more space for the analysis.
Here's the state just
prior to the measurements, which are standard basis measurements of the top or rightmost n qubits.
So the measurement
corresponds to the second cat.
Let's denote by p of y, the probability that the measurements give us the string y for each possible y.
And if we follow the rules from Lesson 2, we get that each of these probabilities is the Euclidean norm squared of whatever vector is tensored
to the standard basis state,
corresponding to why in
our quantum state vector.
That gives us this expression right here.
Now, to get a better handle
on these probabilities, we're gonna need to make
use of some notation, and you might already be
familiar with this notation
because it's pretty common in mathematics.
First, when we refer to the
range of the function f, we just mean the set of all the strings that can come out of this function.
So it's the set of all f of x ranging over all the possible
choices of an input string x.
Second, we're gonna use this notation that you see right here to mean the set of all the input strings x
that f maps to a given string z, for whatever choice of
z we wanna consider.
It kind of looks like the
inverse of the function f, but it's not really the inverse because f is not necessarily invertible.
We also see that we have
a set as the argument on the left hand side, and in this case, it's the set containing
just a single string z,
and that's the clue we need to recognize that we're not talking about
the inverse of the function f, this is called the pre-image.
The pre-image can be
defined more generally for any set given as an argument, not just the set containing
a single element,
but this is all that we're gonna need. It's not the greatest
notation in the world because it's easy to
confuse it with the inverse,
but it's clear enough
and it's widely used, so we're gonna go with it.
And now if we use this notation, we can rewrite the vector that we're taking the
Euclidean norm squared of to get the probability for
measuring each string y.
We're doing this because we need to see
what the coefficients are for each individual standard basis state, and that's not clear from
this expression right here,
because, in general, we may
have multiple choices of x giving us the same string f of x.
In essence, all we're doing
is splitting up the sum over x by first summing overall
z in the range of f,
and then inside of that sum, summing over all x in the pre-image of z, or to be more accurate,
the pre-image of the set
containing the string z.
That lets us replace f of x with z inside of the cat right here.
And the sum overall, the different strings
x that f maps to each z are collected into the
coefficient for each cat.
We're basically putting strings into bins, summing over the bins, and then summing over
the strings in each bin,